now
what is this sakuga that i'm talking
about technically speaking it basically
means
animation that's very mundane right but
of course that's not how we use it and
for the anime fan
sakuraga means impressive animation and
i mean
impressive animation that could be
considered a visual miracle a recent
example would be the most iconic scene
in demon slayer you know the one that
blew up the internet
just so we can get it out of the way
sakura in its colloquial term refers to
a scene or even a moment where the
animation quality just
elevates in quality going full overdrive
and driving the fan base nuts so today
i'll be going through 10 of the fights
in anime with the most breathtaking
animation
however i won't just be ranking them
based on animation but also on scale and
stakes
or just plain emotional investment for
me but before that click the subscribe
button ring the bell
and let's get going
am i correct in assuming that if you've
been an anime fan for the past five
years or so
you would have heard about mob psycho
and how it has such amazing animation to
the point where there was actual drama
when the show didn't win some online
polls for the best animation and the
like that's wild if you ask me to be
fair the angry mob
no pun intended did have a point exhibit
a
mob versus morgami one could argue that
mob psycho is pretty much a chain of
fights filled with breathtaking
animation
but i think this one stands out as it
happens early in the second season
and sets expectations for the rest of
the series expectations
that were easily met by the godly anime
staff this ain't one punch man with a
cursed season 2
folks it's a pivotal moment in mob's
character development
and a breathtaking display of japanese
animation prowess
i can't be the only one who got chills
when mom breaks through mogami after
recapturing his resolve
now that i've shown you this treat for
your eyes perhaps you want to try
jumping into the mob psycho train too
next it's a fight from castlevania yes
sir
castlevania is an american production
but it looks very anime right
and it has a source material that's
japanese so i guess it counts
hey now i've talked about chinese anime
on this channel before so it's only fair
to include something from the west now
isn't it but seriously though do we
really care too much about
technicalities when we have one hell of
a fight between trevor belmont and death
the fight has no shortage of epic
moments to help capture the adrenaline
of playing the original games
the camera angles and the intense motion
captures really hammer home the impact
of jumping around
while fighting death himself the
dramatic comeback by belmont is one of
my favorite moments in the whole
castlevania series
it's not too bad it's not too bad at all
probably something that would make you
want to check out castlevania right
while it's a far cry from the
traditional definitions of sakuga
given the context of the production this
is a damn good fight
it's been a while but i think it's the
perfect time to talk about this fight
again
after all for those of you who are new
to the channel it's probably your first
time being introduced to this
masterpiece in animation one of the best
fight scenes in anime
if we're solely talking about the amount
of effort exerted in animating a
sequence so smoothly
just let the clip speak for itself i
think that a key in keeping your viewers
engaged is to just wow them with smooth
animation
and wow else this show did with its
display of superb martial arts and
hand-to-hand combat
unfortunately the show is not too
popular and for the casual viewer the
fight unfortunately
may not mean too much
jjk jjk where do we start to help damper
the unfortunate news about the manga
recently let's look at one of the many
many breathtaking action sequences that
the show has to offer honestly speaking
there's a lot to pick from
i'm not even sure which one to feature
for my list but after much deliberation
i decided to go for the yuji and todo
fight versus hanami
why well it's simple this fight for me
is probably the fastest paced fight that
requires so much more animation prowess
to pull off the characters go at it from
the start and you can just get lost at
the amount of fluid movement that
attacks your eyes
it helps that the fight has a lot of
ways to keep you engaged mostly through
the techniques being put on display
you've got to watch this fight it's no
question that the animation will blow
you away but the application of teamwork
and various techniques used in synergy
is also a sight to see
i also like how yuji and todo didn't win
the fight technically they had to stall
and survive
long enough for gojo to arrive and do
his thing and that my friends
is yet another visual spectacle to end
the awesomeness of the whole
[Music]
thing
broly is on a roll not only is his
appearance in dragon ball super one of
the iconic moments thanks to that spine
chilling transformation
more on that in this other video his
fight against gogeta is one for the ages
thanks to the wonders of modern
technology the broly and the gojita that
we've known from the old days have been
reborn in amazing fashion
as expected from a theatrical production
the animation is just top notch
and it really recaptures the heat of the
battle between two of the most powerful
beings in the dragon ball universe
both fans of the old days looking for
nostalgia or the newer viewers the dbs
got would just love this fight
paying to see the movie live will
forever be a purchase that i will never
ever regret we rarely see gogeta in
action but he never disappoints when he
sets out to kick ass
this is just one of the many fights that
we'll remember the series 4.
with a fight that has a foregone
conclusion there are a few things you
can do to make it interesting the
biggest and easiest way in my opinion
is to have the whole thing look so over
the top to the point where the audiences
will remember it for years to come
that my friends is how i'll evaluate
saitama
versus boros we all know saitama's gonna
win this one anyway
so the question is a matter of how is he
gonna win how is it gonna look well
if attacks as over the top as the ones
borrows through is your thing
you've come to the right place watching
the fight again i can almost feel the
impact from boris's attacks
attacks that seem more than capable of
planetary destruction
in the end boris's trump card is no
match for cytham a serious punch
and we put an end to this chapter of one
punch man in probably
the most visually impactful way possible
what you think that just because i
mentioned episode 19 in the intro we
won't be having any demon
slayer well especially since the
record-breaking movie just got released
not too long ago bringing with it the
fight animations and effects that we've
long known ufo table for
yes that's right we have akaza vs
rengoku as our fourth place entry for
the list for a good reason
it's more than five minutes of simple
non-stop action featuring the techniques
in the art style that have long become
demon slayer's signatures
only now being available on the big
screen you can see how much
better everything looks for those who
haven't read the manga the fight also
came at an opportune time just when you
thought that everything's over
here comes this far more powerful demon
who pushes the fire hashira way beyond
his limits
it's a fight filled to the brim with
emotion and stakes and the fight is the
one that leads to the tearfield
conclusion of the movie
it's one of the most moving fights in
anime movie history for me
[Music]
we've got more theatrical productions
coming up and this is a fight that i've
spent quite a lot of time talking about
hey i can't help it because it's really
that good we're talking about the climax
of sword of the stranger to be fair most
of the movies fight scenes can qualify
as you can see with that early sequence
of luo lang soloing those poor falls
however
i got a lot more into it when the time
for the final battle came
sword of the stranger stands out from
the other titles on this list because
it's one of the titles
that doesn't involve those supernatural
powers or whatnot
just good old swordsmanship and it's
fights like these that must be so well
animated in order to captivate the
audience luolang vs nanashi
almost single-handedly makes the movie
worth watching but i'd say that the
entire movie is good
not just this part still though it's the
standout that i'll always remember the
film for
talk about the good old days huh seeing
naruto and sasuke fight together brings
back some memories and this
is the one moment that the creators just
cannot afford to screw up in boruto
thankfully they passed the test with
flying colours and gave us this visual
spectacle of a fight
it's really a pleasure to see some call
backs to the old abilities that have
become some of the most iconic parts of
the franchise
of course it's made even better with the
updated visuals and the very intriguing
turns of events in the fight itself i
was at the edge of my seat when i first
saw this fight
and it felt like a reunion filled with
suspense and tension
the fight is good and all but i think
the saddest part of this is how much it
reminds us of good old naruto
and given how much effort got put into
this fight and how beautiful it looked
i'd like to think that the animators are
kind of in the same boat
at the top of the list is none other
than you guessed it
saber versus ryder and shiro
how could we have a list of breathtaking
fight sequences without featuring
probably the holy grail of big screen
productions in that regard
the heavens field trilogy has been
nothing short of breathtaking with its
animation on the fight sequences
and the third movie gave us the pinnacle
of it all the saber versus rider in
shiro fight is something that i've been
so excited to see when i started
following the series
then the trailer hit then the actual
film hit and let's just say
i was completely captivated by the
glorious animation in the real thing
i won't go as far as to say that nothing
will compare to this fight in the film
trilogy but it's got a pretty damn
secure grip on the top spot for me
there could be some arguments for some
to consider the berserker versus saber
fight
and it's a valid point but for me i
think there's just far more stakes and
emotional investment in this fight and
we know that it's the magic ingredient
to help push a fight further and with
that in mind i put this as my number one
breathtaking battle in anime
and i'm curious if you'd agree or not
feel free to chime in on the comments
section while you're at it
that brings us to the end of this list
if you enjoyed the countdown hit that
like button and share this video with
your friends
maybe it can catch their attention and
you can help them join the wonderful
world of anime now if you really enjoyed
the countdown video you might want to
consider supporting the channel through
our two avenues
membership and patreon subbing to either
of these services will give you access
to their respective perks
and you can help support the channel in
a big way i wish you a good day ahead
and i thank you for watching this video
i'd love to see you next time this is
vinnie tube checking out
[Music]
[Applause]
you